how are you ad great rich okay so we
heard mike tomlin say he's gonna keep
things in-house heck of a house that
we're keeping things in right now what
what do you know about Antonio Browns
absence and how it might mean for
anything other than just what he took it
for well I think he was very upset on
Sunday I was obvious on the field on the
sidelines bolded out of the locker room
with his agent and todra Rosenhaus and
then had that tweak you know trade me
the trade meet week at any stayed away
and Mike said he wouldn't say whether it
was excused or not which tells everybody
it wasn't excused so that's where we sit
until they talk it out and work it out I
can't imagine him sitting them down for
a game or anything though rich that
would just make the rest of the team
suffer yeah I mean who is Ryan Scarpino
who he was responding to who worked for
the team for all those years and does he
voice anything that might be a
legitimate belief held within the front
offices of the Pittsburgh Steelers that
and Antonio Brown owes the team and and
been robbing no I don't think I Ryan as
prolific on Twitter now that he's not an
employee anymore he was in the PR office
good guy very helpful to us then he was
there for around five six years maybe
and just decided he was gonna go and
pursue some other work and he did he
works like he works for the county here
okay in Allegheny County so I'm just
saying it's like why would a Antonio
Brown feel the need to pop back at him
that's what I'm saying is that is this
something that that he might be touching
on that is being played out behind the
scenes that Antonio Brown feels slighted
in any way shape or form yeah I don't
think so we we've we've wondered if a
Antonio even knows that Ryan doesn't
work for the team anymore okay um you
know because yeah hey these guys you
know they pay attention to some things
and not to others but uh you know Ryan
worked until last summer for the team
and
he's been gone not this pass on our a
year ago is it anyway is there any way
that what Antonio Brown may have given
voice on the sidelines have anything to
do with Le'Veon Bell not being there and
just being part and parcel of whatever
anxiety has been stirred up by the
withholding of levy on services by said
running back my opinion no rich I think
it's pure selfish on his part that he's
not getting the statistics he's used to
he's only averaging eight point nine a
catch now whose fault is that they're
thrown on the ball out thirty three
targets and two games he hasn't you know
it hasn't caught any big ones yet he
hasn't he does have one touchdown
against Cleveland but um he's done this
before he's just um he seems to be taken
in an extra step this time you know he
threw up a big fit in Baltimore last
year when Ben didn't see him when he was
open and right when somewhere else right
I do remember that a couple more minutes
here with that boo chef Pittsburgh
post-gazette and what is the latest with
the Steelers in levy on bail and is
there any latest I mean what how is how
can you tell us this is playing out
right now yeah same old same old rich
nobody seems to know you know I mean
when his own teammates thought he was
coming in they thought they were led to
believe he was coming in for the first
game and he never showed you saw their
reaction and all we seen hop it on my
might I follow him on TMZ because they
keep coming up with stuff of him
partying in clubs in South Beach and now
he's on a jet ski in South Beach so
seems to be living it up Wow I mean so
is there any sense at all of the
Steelers making a maneuver to get him in
by sweetening the tender just that to
figure out that to win a Super Bowl this
year and to remove all of whatever
distraction as de Castro called last
week draining to try and remove that
themselves rich I can guarantee you one
thing I don't know a lot of what's gonna
go on with Bill I can guarantee you one
thing the Steelers are not gonna sweeten
the offer either comes in and plays or
he doesn't and that's gonna be that so
why you think they're gonna trade him
why but
because they that's the way they are if
they sweeten the offer for a lot of
reasons it would they don't like setting
precedents and that would set a
precedent for the next franchise player
and it's just not going to happen I
could tell you it won't happen so does
he come in week 11 based on you say or
does he what do you think he read that
the next step again rich I don't know I
mean I don't know how long he's gonna
hold up he's missing 850 6,000 he's
given up every week until he does and
you do the math ten weeks and then is
let's just say after ten weeks he does
report they can get a roster exemption
for two weeks and not pay them for those
two weeks so that'd be another 1.7 he'd
miss how ugly is this in the compared to
anything you've seen in Pittsburgh Edie
it's getting there
you know I was just trying to put down a
lot of this stuff there's not a lot of
things happen here and there's been a
Ben Roethlisberger starting the season
with a four-game suspension by the NFL
that was kind of ugly
they started out on four back in
thirteen that was that was kind of
interesting because the year before they
tumbled out of the playoff picture by
losing four their last five so they had
lost eight out of the last nine games
and Mike Tomlin was on a hot seat that
Edie thanks for the call appreciate it I
have a feeling we're gonna be calling
you back very soon okay
you got it you got that said Bichette
fresh off of the press conference today
with Mike Tomlin the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience